people think that modern technology is
somehow changing love it's not changing
love the basic brain system for romantic
love evolved millions of years ago it's
not going to change whether you meet
somebody on tinder on match.com or in
the library or on the skating rink or in
church the brain doesn't change and the
moment that you meet somebody in a
coffee house in a bar on a park bench
wherever it is the ancient human brain
clicks into action and we court the way
we always have we smile the way we
always have we flirt the way we always
have we listen the way we always have we
try to size up the person the way the
brain has always been sizing people up
but modern technology is changing how we
court in fact you know I work match com
the internet dating site then I'm their
chief scientific advisor and they have
an algorithm there's all kinds of
algorithms out there but these are not
dating sites these are introducing sites
once you go out with the person and meet
them wherever you're going to meet them
the ancient human brain clicks into
action and your court the way we always
have but they are introducing sites and
their algorithms are very useful i mean
you know most of us have this love map
of what we're looking for and you've got
to pair up somebody you have to offer
dates of the right age the right
proximity whether there are five miles
away or 50 miles away the right
background the right educational level
some of the right interests so dating
sites can go so far only so far with
their algorithms to give you the broad
basics of what you're looking for that
we can provide for you so that you spend
less time you know kissing frogs
you